des dizaines de débris sur la route 112
à Marieville qui ne laisse aucun doute
sur la force de l'impact la collision
frontale a été provoquée par une voiture
qui s'est retrouvée dans la voie inverse
la motocycliste dans la cinquantaine n'a
eu aucune chance elle a été éjectée de
sa moto ça passagère une jeune femme
dans la vingtaine est toujours à
l'hôpital dans un état critique deux
occupants de la voiture qui a dévié de
sa trajectoire ont également été
recondues dans un centre hospitalier de
la région il s'agissait du cinquième
accident mortel impliquant des
motocyclistes au terme de week-end
meurtrier sur les roues du Québec
à chaque début de saison c'est un peu la
même cassette qui repart on est un peu
rouillé les routes sont pas totalement
propres on s'entend et puis les gens ont
perdu un petit peu le réflexe de
regarder
d'abord vendredi soir un homme de 39 ans
lui aussi tué dans une collision
mortelle avec une voiture à cette île au
cours de la même soirée une femme de 32
ans a perdu la vie dans une sortie de
route au volant de sa moto à
Saint-Médard dans le Bas-Saint-Laurent
samedi a été tout aussi tragique avec la
mort de motocycliste de 39 ans à Lévis
dans une bretelle de l'autoroute 20 puis
un homme de 47 ans a perdu la vie en
perdant la maîtrise de sa moto à
Saguenay durant la pandémie il y a
beaucoup de monde qui ont repris la moto